hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
gamespot here in the Nintendo booth at
e3 2014 sitting here with my new friend
Christina who works with game developers
for Nintendo how you feeling in this
very full and very exciting booth
Christina very energized very excited
it's a lot of fun I came in and I asked
you what's like the one thing I really
really should look at here in the booth
and you mentioned splatoon widest
platoon so exciting it is ok so it's
nintendo's new IP and basically it's um
we have four players playing four
players this is going to be an online
game and it's basically a third-person
shooter and so everybody it's a teams of
four and what you're actually trying to
do is get your color ink all over so
it's basically you're trying to take up
all of the space with your ink you can
actually shoot each other with your ink
or you know and it's it's very
competitive and it gets really exciting
when people like when you're really
really close and then the end and they
add up who has the most it's actually
turf so who has the most turf and then
just you know cheers and whoever lost
and won it's just really fun well so the
objective is to claim as much turf as I
can for my team and then the shooting
aspect is just keeping other people away
from getting turf well in the way that
you get the turf is you're actually
shooting ink and so it's your ink is
coloring the ground and the walls and
the trees and then you can also ink your
opponent's which will send them back to
their base and they have to start over
so you're actually changing between a
person and a squid and so as a squid you
can actually like go through the ink and
like pick recharges your ink and there I
saw it's like swimming sorry inkling
Inklings yeah so yeah they're kind of
swimming that's adorable yeah and it's a
lot of fun it's a lot of fun it's gonna
be really fun to be competing with
people and just so so I can go online on
my wii u and i can connect with my
friends online and then we can go in and
play against other teams exactly
so four on four and I can play against
random people or make custom matches is
that we haven't actually announced yet
yeah basically I mean just here it's
just four on four and yeah we have
people here playing for against more in
person so up here on the top we have
four against four down here we have four
against four so and we do have a line of
people waiting to play the game so so
you better come get in there if you want
to play this at all so you know one
thing I noticed we're talking about this
colored ink all over the turf and
everything this game immediately drew my
eye because of that color and that's
something that I personally notice a lot
in games as i prefer games with a lot
more color and that tends to be a trend
with Nintendo would you say that's
something that is done intentionally I
would say so I mean it just I think
personally like a lot of color it does
it just brings people's attention and
it's fun and it's happy and you know it
just really makes you smile it's like a
rainbow so and you know shooting people
with colored ink is a little you know
happier than necessarily shooting
someone with it in grey with you know
lots of different more morbid colors I
suppose now all you're using is ink it's
still just as competitive though you'd
see a lot of splattering really success
there satisfying splattering noises and
animation yeah definitely and if you
look you can see up there and we've got
splatters up on the wall and so yeah
it's it's very satisfying game so I'm
seeing a lot of trends toward kind of
multiplayer and connecting with your
friends online in in all of the consoles
and especially in Nintendo what I'm
brought about that change do you think I
think one of our main focuses is
bringing people together I mean you know
a lot of times people just sit and play
their video games by themselves and one
a Nintendo's biggest focuses is it is
it's really bringing people together and
making it fun and making it interactive
and so people are engaged and enjoying
each other and having fun like you know
the old school video games where
everybody's sitting around playing you
know Mario and passing the control
around so it doesn't really engages
people and brings them back together
absolutely I think one of my favorite
gaming experiences was playing mario
party in college with all my friends so
now in my wii u connecting with all my
friends online has been really great too
yeah exactly and it gets as it
keeps you connected and keeps you
talking and having fun with other people
so I'm really looking forward to
splatoon thanks so much for introducing
it to me a great day